sin comida deshidratados y a la deriva
cientos de personas que emigraron de sus
países con destino a europa fueron
rescatadas en aguas del mar mediterráneo
por la organización sin ánimo de lucro
si watch el xi watch 4 ha rescatado a
otras 107 personas de un barco de madera
en peligro entre ellos se encuentra un
bebé de un día de nacido ahora hay 482
pasajeros en nuestro barco que necesitan
desembarcar en un puerto seguro lo antes
posible a pesar de las malas condiciones
meteorológicas no cesan de zarpar botes
rumbo a europa pero no toda la migración
ilegal se realiza en embarcaciones
precarias existe también una ruta
reservada a quienes pueden pagar más
familias enteras de afganos iraquíes
iraníes y kurdos desembolsan hasta nueve
mil seiscientos dólares por persona para
acceder a veleros de lujo que están
haciendo la ruta desde turquía hasta la
región de calabria en el sur de italia
las embarcaciones no despiertan
sospechas y según las autoridades los
viajes son organizados por coyotes de
ucrania y turquía cuando llegan los
migrantes son ubicados en centros de
detención temporales
en nuestra vida no era segura en kabul
vinieron los talibanes yo era abogada no
puedo vivir en kabul a causa de ellos
debo dejar afganistán antes
fue un viaje difícil
y vimos a irán y luego a turquía e
italia estuvimos viajando tres meses
entrar
según cifras de la agencia de la onu
para los refugiados a mediados de
noviembre llegaron a calabria
9.687 migrantes casi cuatro veces más
que en el mismo periodo del año pasado
además el ministerio del interior de
italia informó que más de 61 mil
migrantes han desembarcado en el país
este año frente a los 32 mil 476 en el
mismo periodo en 2020